[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le 7-8 loisirs toutes vos
idées sorties dans le département on
commence tôt quitte avec le sommaire de
ce numéro une fête et un concert au
profit des enfants malades le village
seniors orpea de soi rémy les chevreuse
organise un événement solidaire ce week
end
les fonds récoltés iront pour
l'association imagine fort margot la
responsable de cette opération nous
dévoilera le programme
les abeilles sont en voie de disparition
en france et dans le monde la france
miniature des activités sont proposées
pour les découvrir et apprendre comment
les protéger
ce dimanche c'est la fête des pères et
vous n'avez pas encore d'idées cadeaux
pas de panique pour notre rendez-vous
junior mélanie poker nous présentera un
travail manuel facile à réaliser
mais tout d'abord place au théâtre dans
tous ses états un festival de théâtre
amateur se déroulera du 20 au 25 juin à
la ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt pour
l'occasion plusieurs troupe associative
notamment à nîmes europe et le
technocentre de renault se partageront
la scène pendant une semaine vous
pourrez les retrouver à partir de 20h30
en semaine et en fin d'après midi le
dimanche
pour yoann lavabre directeur de la ferme
de bel ébat c'est un moyen de
communiquer la passion du théâtre en
écoute l'idée l'idée c'est de partager
moi je crois que pendant pendant
longtemps les les théâtres les théâtres
professionnels se sont un peu coupé des
milieux amateur et je crois que c'est
une erreur fondamentale on a on a besoin
évidemment de faire la distinction entre
le théâtre amateur et le théâtre
professionnel
mais une fois que cette distinction est
faite il est il est très très important
de créer des liens des passerelles entre
ces deux univers
il faut pas oublier que les amateurs de
théâtre ce sont d'abord des gens qui
aiment le théâtre et donc des gens à qui
nous devons ouvrir les portes toutes les
représentations wii sont gratuites
on peut prendre les places directement
au guichet du théâtre ou sur le kiosque
un concert qui pourrait ravir les
passionnés de musique 140 personnes
unissent leurs voix pour chanter de la
variété francophone de jean jacques
goldman à céline dion qu'un raccord
c'est le nom de ce groupe vocal il
ronde trois concerts exceptionnels
vendredi soir samedi soir et dimanche
après midi à la mairie de trappes
après deux ans d'entraînement ces
représentations sont un aboutissement
pour emmanuel comptait présidente du
groupe vocal choeur accord elle était au
micro de mélanie poker c'est forcément
un aboutissement de notre travail sur
deux ans mais pas que c'est aussi
vraiment
du plaisir qu'on prend tout au long de
l'année et
et voilà de monter sur scène et de
montrer notre travail nous rend
forcément un petit peu excitée et ravie
de pouvoir montrer notre notre travail à
tous nos spectateurs une opération
solidaire au profit de la recherche
enfants sans cancer c'est ce week end au
village seniors orpea de saint rémy les
chevreuse une grande fête autour d'un
vide greniers et un concerts sont
proposés au grand public
jennifer caron directrice de
l'établissement nous a rejoint bonjour
bonjour alors je l'évoqué rapidement à
l'instant où l'on va redonner le
programme de ce week end ce sont deux
jours de festivités avec un concert jazz
le samedi soir ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus oui effectivement nous
soutenons l'association imagine fort
margot et afin de récolter des fonds
pour cette association nous avons repris
l'initiative avec les salariés de
l'établissement mais aussi les résidents
de l'établissement d'organiser des
actions ouverte au grand public qui vont
permettre en fait de récolter des fonds
et là ce week-end nous avons la chance
d'accueillir un groupe de jazz pour un
apéro jazz samedi à 19 heures ainsi
qu'un vide greniers qui débutera samedi
matin jusqu'à dimanche soir
on trouvera de nombreuses curiosités
donc ça c'est tout le week-end et ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un petit mot sur
le groupe comment il s'appelle et
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont jouer un petit peu
s'appelle les éphémères un groupe un
collectif jazz et soul en fait c'est
l'association deux groupes amateurs
on a sur scène neuf musiciens de
chanteurs de chanteurs un chanteur ou
une chanteuse de choristes qui vont
reprendre des morceaux connus
on peut évoquer stevie wonder michael
jackson ou d'autres morceaux aussi
dessous française comme ben l'oncle soul
par exemple donc des morceaux assez
connu du grand public et de vous l'avez
dit donc tous les fonds récoltés seront
reversés à l'association imagine fort
margot qui soutient qui soutient la
recherche contre le cancer et notamment
des enfants
ambiance à fait en fait le groupe orpea
depuis 20 ans a toujours en fait
favorisé les liens intergénérationnels
pour permettre en fait à nos résidents
de garder une vie institutionnelle de
garder un rôle dans la société et de
pouvoir aussi développé des liens
sociaux et au travers des initiatives
que qui sont dans le groupe depuis
toutes ces années on a très souvent en
fait soutenu des associations de
proximité locale qui vont soutenir et
aider au bien-être des jeunes parce que
pour nos aînés
l'avenir de leurs enfants de leurs
petits-enfants de leur arrière petits
enfants est très important et donc ils
se rendent utiles ils ont plein de
ressources et plein de savoir aussi à
communiquer aux enfants et au sein de la
résidence saint rémy on a l'habitude de
travailler avec des écoles avec des
centres de loisirs et d'organiser des
événements de ce type pour le plus grand
bonheur de nos résidents mais aussi des
enfants qui viennent sur le site et vous
l'avez dit justement c'est comment dire
c'est favoriser le lien
intergénérationnel vous avez organisé
d'autres animations il y en a d'autres
encore à venir qui auront lieu notamment
jusqu'en septembre
qu'est ce que nous attendons ce concept
alors justement c'est d'avoir
effectivement ce week-end nous avons
ce vide-greniers ce concert apéro jazz
précédemment on est nous avions
participé au festival jazz à toute heure
de la vallée de chevreuse on avait la
chance d'accueillir début mars
aussi un groupe de jazz les oignons on a
organisé dans le cadre site du salon du
livre lire en val avec les écoles des
ateliers de création pour décorer des
boules chinoises lumineuse puisque
c'était le thème de la lumière donc là
par exemple sont les résidents qui vont
dans les écoles créées ces boules
chinoises avec les enfants qui servent
après la déclaration du salon et
inversement les enfants viennent aussi à
la résidence donc il ya un vrai lien
nous attendons ce que je veux vous le
coupez mais on a d'autres choses à une
émission bien chargé là ce sont les
résidents qui organise donc en fait
cette brocante alors ce qu'on y trouve
on y trouve des choses différentes et de
vieux vinyles de vieux meubles des
choses un peu plus récente délivre un
barbecue qui est organisée samedi soir
en même temps que le jazz en fait que le
concert de jazz
la vente aussi de boissons de choses
comme celle ci et tout cela donc tous
les bons en fait doivent être réglés
sous la forme soit chèque soit deux
cartes bancaires de manière à ce que ça
soit versée directement à l'association
imagine fort margot oui j'allais venir
très rapidement justement l'heure les
modalités c'est l'entrée est libre mais
on peut faire des dons du coup par le
vieux que vous avez vous fait le don se
fait au travers de l'achat
symboliquement vous allez acheter un
objet au lieu de régler cet objet vous
allez faire le don à l'association qui
correspond au montant de 2 ce que vous
allez négocier avec les résidents qui
vendent leurs objets d'accord parfait en
tout cas merci beaucoup d'univers caron
d'être venu sur notre plateau pour
parler de cet événement
vous êtes attendus nombreux pour
participer en tout cas ce week end
festif et solidaire on le rappelle ça se
passe jusqu'au dimanche 18 juin au
village seniors orpea avec un concert
jazz samedi soir merci beaucoup jennifer
de la route ce sont de petits ouvrière
est essentielle à notre alimentation les
abeilles sont à l'honneur tout le mois
de juin à france miniature
elles sont menacées de disparition et le
parc organise donc tous les dimanches
des animations pour sensibiliser le
public à la protection des abeilles
reportage sur les images d'yves pujol
berger devrait cours mans de ses
abeilles une goutte de miel sur le doigt
permet de les attirer à coup sûr mais au
delà de l'aspect amusant c'est une
manière de les apprivoiser et surtout de
les comprendre
thierry et christine sont apiculteur
depuis deux ans ils transmettent leur
passion
le fait aussi de les voir disparaître
dans nos jardins petit à petit le fait
d'entendre qu'elle disparaisse dans le
monde que la pollinisation est mise en
danger que par exemple dans certaines
régions de chine les hommes sont obligés
de faire de la pollinisation à la main
parce qu'il ya plus d'insectes
pollinisateurs par esther naturellement
quand mes enfants sont devenir grand et
que j'ai eu plus de temps j'installe ma
première ruche dans mon jardin et j'ai
contacté france miniature pour
sensibiliser les gens découverte de
l'intérieur d'une ruche et animations
autour du miel france miniature confirme
son engagement pour la préservation des
abeilles
le parc n'utilise plus de pesticides les
fleurs sont laisser plus longtemps dans
les pelouse et deux ruches ont été
installées pour les enfants on propose
des ateliers où on leur fait construire
une petite abeille fabriqués une abeille
en papier on propose également des
ateliers de fabrication bougies en cire
d'abeille et puis c'est vraiment
l'occasion pour nous de passer des
messages pour que les gens soient
sensibilisés au fait que l'abeille noire
notamment qui est une abeille locale est
en voie de disparition donc on explique
avec quels gestes simples on peut faire
en sorte de la préserver ça leur permet
de s'apprivoiser un petit peu avec le
monde de la nature de poser toutes leurs
questions de façon ludique ces
butineuses se laisse approcher par les
visiteurs tous les dimanches du mois de
juin
thierry et christine donne même des
conseils pour les accueillir dans vos
jardins
[Musique]
après les mamans au mois de mai c'est au
tour des papas d'être célébré la fête
des pères c'est ce dimanche 18 juin et
cette semaine on vous propose une petite
idée cadeau à faire vous même une carte
pour trois fois rien bonjour mélanie
besoin de camille et là en fait elle est
la voile à savoir super mignon alors on
sait il faut quelques feuilles
cartonnées pour commencer moi j'ai
choisi une blanche pour faire la carte
des feuilles de couleur la bleue pour
fois coloré l'extérieur le de la rose
pour pour le coeur et une paire de
ciseaux des feutres un crayon de la
colle à 2 td des éléments qu'on a tous
dans une trousse ou à la maison
et alors il faut tout d'abord d'écoeurer
pour décorer le coeur pardon il faut
aussi une moustache et le poème parle et
que vous avez un prix mais justement
mais alors il faut peu de matériel c'est
une création assez rapide oui ok mais ça
m'a pris environ une vingtaine de
minutes alors la première étape c'est
tout simple on va le voir à l'image il
faut plier la feuille blanche car tenez
en deux si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez
aussi le faire on papiers colorés
après vous prenez une règle alors du
côté de la pliure et faire un petit
réveil 8 cm un deuxième verre 9 cm dans
l'intérieur vous calculez 4 cm et après
vous allez voir vous allez découpé et
inverser la plus dure vingt l'intérieur
voilà pour la pille on va permettre de
coller le coeur justement si vous passez
au coeur alors il faut prendre un joli
coeur
un gros j'ai imprimé un modèle que je
reporte sur ma feuille rose
voilà vous faites bien le contour et
vous découpez là aussi ce choeur et le
coller à l'intérieur de la carte sur la
bandelette collait bien pour pas qu'ils
s'en aillent et vous faites pareil pour
la moustache vous allez le voir on prend
bien son temps on suit bien les contours
et après une colle le tout alors j'ai
choisi une moustache mais vous pouvez
faire un autre signe distinctif de votre
papa pourquoi pas la bouche ses lunettes
ses yeux et pour terminer sur le cas où
vous faites un vous prenez le fait
pardon et vous dressez les yeux et pour
le message destiné aux papas mélanie
vous avez choisi un poème de maurice
carême le poète belge on tourne à tous
après un jour à l'école un poème moi
j'ai pris le parti de l'imprimé mais
pourquoi pas l'écrire si vous avez aussi
une jolie écriture puis ça ça ça permet
aussi d'identifier un peu plus le
message
alors après on passe à l'intérieur de la
carte si vous avez choisi ne feuille
cartonnée colorés vous reste plus qu'à
écrire un petit mot pourquoi pas un
simple bonne fête papa
moi j'ai choisi de compléter avec mike
hart une feuille bleue claire toute
simple je la colle sur la devant le
devant de la garde produit je découvre
tout ce qui dépasse il vous reste encore
un peu de temps pour réaliser cette
jolie carte merci en tout cas mélanie
nous avoir présenté cette idée cadeau on
passe maintenant à notre agenda
[Musique]
samedi 17 juin maurepas organise une
grande fête populaire pour célébrer son
arrivée au sein de la ville nouvelle
il ya 50 ans au programme fanfare jeux
gonflables exposition historique et
d'automobiles rendez vous à 18h30 sur la
place jacques riboud le 21 juin pour la
fête de la musique cover trempe se
produira à bois d'arcy le groupe de
reprises de supertramp et le seul
tribute band français il a été et clamé
par l'ancien chanteur de la formation
rodger hodgson et on se quitte en
musique je vous propose d'écouter
justement un petit extrait on se
retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]
st
je suis
[Musique]
vous